I am a planet hunter
and keeper of the keys
at NASA's Exoplanet Archive.
In March 2022, we reached
a major milestone in space exploration:
5,000 known exoplanets.
For thousands of years,
we've wondered about planets
outside of our solar system,
now called exoplanets.
But our technology only recently
caught up with our imaginations.
And yes, 5,000 planets is incredible.
What's even more incredible
is how space research
will change as a result.
When I started grad school,
there were about 100 known exoplanets,
all radically different
from the Earth and from each other.
I was determined to find more.
I spent four years looking
at nearly 87,000 stars, one by one.
Now you might have this romantic idea
that I was gazing intently
through a telescope,
pondering some gorgeous view
of the universe.
I was not.
I was looking at data like this,
measuring the brightness
of each star over time.
If the brightness dipped, just briefly,
just a little bit,
it could be because a planet
had orbited in front of that star,
blocking some of the light
from reaching my telescope.
So I spent four years looking
for decimal-level changes in these data.
And after four years, I'd found ...
nothing.
Zero exoplanets.
Thankfully, they still gave me the PhD,
I think, for effort.
(Laughter)
Then I moved to Harvard, where I worked
on my first NASA mission, called EPOXI.
I still didn't find any exoplanets.
Then in March 2010,
I joined the Kepler Mission,
NASA's grand experiment
with putting one of our planet-hunting
instruments into space.
Monday was my first day
on the base in Silicon Valley.
It was mostly spent in HR.
Tuesday, I sat down and looked
at the data for the first time,
and I found my first exoplanet.
(Cheers)
(Applause)
A few minutes later, I found another one.
There's a saying that we're the generation
that was born too late to explore Earth
and too soon to explore space.
That's not true anymore.
That day and every day since,
I've gotten to explore space.
Kepler made it possible for us
to measure stellar brightness
much more precisely
than we had before.
And eventually I helped find
thousands of exoplanets.
And we've really only searched
our local corner of the galaxy
to find those planets.
That means there's likely tens of billions
of planets just in our Milky Way.
Now with so much data,
we can start sorting and grouping
and categorizing these planets
to find trends.
Think of it this way:
if you wanted to learn about dogs
and you had five dogs in your study,
well, you'd learn a lot
about those five dogs.
That they're all good dogs.
But maybe not about dogs in general.
If you had 5,000 dogs in your study,
then you’d start to see that there were
German Shepherds and Dobermanns
and beagles,
and that these different breeds
have different features.
With demographic-level data on exoplanets,
we can start asking some
of these big questions for the first time,
like: Of those thousands and billions
of planets in our galaxy,
how many are like the Earth,
or like Jupiter?
How many planets does a typical star have?
Can a planet orbit more than one star?
Yes.
Can a planet exist
without any star at all?
Also yes.
One surprising result
from the study of planet populations
is that the most common
kind of planet in our galaxy
might be one we don’t have
in our solar system:
a super-Earth up to twice as big
and ten times as heavy as our Earth.
We've found evaporating planets,
disintegrating planets,
planets clustered together
in a clockwork dance,
ultra-puffy planets, ultra-dense planets.
It's truly a wild and wonderful menagerie
that I get to corral
at the NASA Exoplanet Archive.
But it gets even more
interesting than that.
With so much data,
we might finally be able
to figure out how planets are made.
We see baby stars
being born in stellar nurseries
surrounded by dust and gas.
And we see all the stars surrounded
by completed planetary systems.
But we still don't really know
what happens in between.
With more data, we might find planets
at some middle stage
or many middle stages.
And from there, be able to map out
a timeline of planetary development.
What triggers these diffused clouds
of dust and gas to collapse and transform?
And how does the chaos
and turmoil of dust become pebbles,
and pebbles become boulders,
and boulders become planetesimals?
And from there,
after an intense series of bombardments
eventually settle
into an ordered series of planets.
How often is one
of those planets solid and warm,
with a water ocean lapping a sandy shore?
Where do we come from,
and how did we get here?
The more we learn about exoplanets,
the easier it is
to target the ones we want.
So far, we haven't found any planets
that are like the Earth.
But I hope we will.
NASA just spent the last few years
studying the idea
of a very large telescope in space
with next-generation technology
that would allow us to take an image,
an actual photograph,
of a planet like the Earth.
With that photo, we could search
for biomarkers, signatures of life.
I'll probably spend the rest of my career
working on that mission.
I hope I get to take that photo.
Thank you.
(Applause)